thank you so much for coming this
evening see a number of familiar faces I
really appreciate the support
um so Keen to get straight into it but I
guess just to frame this up for those of
you that might not have been to one of
these before we'll probably spend about
30 minutes as guys having a chat uh
within that I've also got a bunch of
questions that some of you submitted
um and then after sort of 30 minutes or
so we'll then bring a mic out into the
audience so for those of you that have
the courage to ask a question and we're
going to encourage that put these guys
on the spot and we can freestyle it a
bit um but hopefully the goal tonight is
that you all walk away with you know
some actionable insights some things
that can help you in your career your
business
um by these lovely people sharing it so
um for those that don't know who you are
let's just start with a brief intro
Lewis I'm going to come to you first and
then just come back around this way
um and then we'll get into it
associate director of wise really we're
a specialist Tech sales recruitment
agency and I'm also the founder of sdis
of London which is a peer-to-peer
mentorship platform for London's best
lead generators let's go
are you sure
um so I am Alicia Birch I am the
business director of Anderson James we
are a thanks mom
um we are a construction business who
Supply across USA London obviously North
West as well UK wide
um yeah I've been doing it for six years
and absolutely loving every second of it
all right let's just go lost one of
these Jamie hi I'm Jamie Fraser CEO of
the interest group sounded interest six
or seven years ago
um at the age of 23 we're now a global
business hundred and forty people free
locations so yeah I hope I can share
some knowledge experience and yeah
awesome no thanks for being there
um so where I wanted to start is just to
have a bit of a reflection
um period so where I wanted to start is
uh a lot of people that I've spoken to
have had a challenging H1
um so I think I'd like let's just kick
this off by sharing maybe some of the
things that you and your team have been
running into at least you're going to
come to first if that's okay
um but yeah I guess I just wanted to
kick started by you know taking a step
back thinking about the first half of
this year what have been you know some
of the challenges that you've been
running into or you keep hearing in the
office that your team are running into
what being some of the major challenges
that you've been working through so I
think for us as you know me personally
as a 360 and also a 180 as well just
doing business development it's been
really really hard to when it when it
comes to Market at the moment it's
harder to hire people don't want as many
people especially in the market that I
do which is construction so it's a lot
harder to actually get people through to
an offer stage but the talent needs to
be a a lot higher and it's a lot harder
to find that Talent you've got to be a
lot more well connected together anyway
and so I do think that at the moment
what we've found is that mainly the job
control is the hardest bit you know we
need to make sure that we're getting
good jobs they're well qualified clients
are on side all those bits that
contribute to actually getting to offer
stage but then also a really
good candidate like that's like the
hardest you know what I mean it's a
candidate-led market recruitment is
candidate-led so as long as you've got
good people and good relationships
you'll be fine
Lewis what what have you got to share on
that yeah so
um all of us that work in Tech I don't
know if Jamie will tell us something
different in a second but the the tech
bubble kind of burst 2021 was like
champagne recruitment era that was
awesome
um and what we had in the tech sales
Market was a number of people generating
promotions just by moving companies in
that time because the first time ever
the first time ever uh jobs outweigh
Talent which was incredible for us but
then yeah it all came crashing down
around about six to nine months ago and
then what happens is there's a surplus
of talent in the market because of mass
redundancies which is not good news for
us yeah that's one of the main
challenges and another one as well which
you know I'm sure we'll talk about later
um is being sent on Wild Goose chases
with contingent terms
yeah they're putting your best football
I see a lot of nodding heads
look you best foot forward and then like
you know putting everything into a
search only to be all about oh all of a
sudden we haven't got a sign off or
we're going to push these roles back to
next queue which you actually told me
about uh exactly so yeah challenges so
yeah flooded amount of people on the
market
um like I said continuing we spoke about
that we're going to talk more about that
okay Jamie from your perspective
obviously maybe you've got a bit more of
a global footprint compared to these
guys all the Alicia's business does do
the US what did you see in the first
half of the year what were some of the
challenges that you were helping your
team overcome
at a start of the year we turn
semi-stoft and that's not who I am or
who we are as a business when I drove
the business at the start is very much
about hard work numbers numbers numbers
um we started adding like my whole goal
for this year was people engagement
taking up people engagement to the next
level why because I want people to be
attracted to our business how we do that
is make sure that we have a platform
that people can join can be part of but
can grow I speak to everyone in my
interviews is that if a company can't
grow you personally or career don't go
down if you don't can't get a goal out
of it so
we added all of these new different
quirky benefits and um like what
was the quirkiest
don't actually like them so I want to
share what were some of the benefits we
we didn't offer sick days then we
started bringing in sick days well wait
what is six days what does that mean so
you can take a sick day and you get paid
paying for us oh wow yeah okay you have
them and they do like people love them
okay so sick days I don't know of them
people yeah okay come on so sick they're
going to talk free quickest and sick day
as well I don't know so we pay sick days
but we also gave them more holidays but
we also added in mental health days okay
but for me if you take a mental health
day you should actually suffer with
mental health right and people obviously
take advantage of that
um what else did we do
element holiday
menstrual leave okay
yeah I mean so
yeah for the women obviously
yeah
so
so that that's obviously been our
challenge I obviously last year everyone
had the percentage optic right this this
year so people have done well last year
did they do well last year they've come
into this year I've got a lot of great
Builders within my business they come
into the issue with big contract books
um what you've done last year is not
going to work this year right and that's
that's the biggest thing that we'd be
trying to Reign back in and drive back
in is high Tempo high quality because
quality is key in this market
um numbers and and just raining stuff
back in and that's obviously been our
challenge in the shift that we're making
as we open up New York which has been
this week
um we've changed all of our structure
from benefits to numbers etc etc so I
think the challenge for us is a lot of
people taking a foot off the gas we
have kind of struggled with that even
though we're growing but that's probably
no I appreciate you sharing that because
look I I said you didn't I want to be
prepared for this that I spoke to a lot
of agency leaders that felt the same
they almost found themselves like
pandering to what they've you know what
employees wanted them to do
um so how if you do it like this is
later on I wanted to be brought up so in
terms of that then what helps your
contact realization because that might
be useful for people like I know you
said that he was in the it might be in a
board meeting I'm not sure but what
helps you come to that realization and
then I've got a follow-up question on
that but what helps you realize that
yeah Roi I think that's his main thing
if you do anything for a business if you
do any sort of benefit or
perk or whatever it is you've got to
check the ROI that you get back from it
and we also had our Fridays go from 5 PM
finish to 3 30 finish or our end of week
sales meeting would be three three
o'clock
our productivity on a Friday was so
that we realized it when I was having
board meetings and my chairman went
that's not you like that is not you as a
business with a couple months that was
80 we're not an 80 Business
um so it was just realization that we
wasn't doing what
our brand is I'll enjoyed our mission
and stuff like that okay cool no I
appreciate you sharing that so because I
know like we all spoke a bit about that
in our own ways so let me bring this
question in then
um Lewis I'm gonna come to you on this
this was a question from Charles I think
it's the right time to ask it so he
asked how uh have you rolled out
company-wide change in cultural
processes mindset to allow them to
succeed what was the pushback and how
has that overcome because I'm sure you
run into that which we'll get on to but
you know Lewis anything to share on
there in terms of how you approach
things I know you saw similar things in
different ways is this the uh return
back to the office question
yeah obviously not the whole you know we
get enough of it on LinkedIn you'll know
where from home the office like
that like let's just keep it real in
terms of you know we're actually trying
to drive in our businesses in the office
yeah look I think a lot of businesses
have been through the same thing haven't
they've it's been like a feeling out
process post covert has talked what they
can do to make sure they keep a high
performing culture but um at the same
time I'll just give you the story of how
we went about it yeah yeah so initially
come without a covered you initially
went back into just doing Wednesdays and
then it got back to three days a week
then you could do any three days a week
that you chose now initially it kind of
worked we were doing it but we found
that we just weren't really hitting the
numbers that we used to and if anything
the culture just got diluted like why is
it really internally within four walls
of wise there is known as like the high
performing log with gritty we get we
roll our sleeves up we're in early we're
last to leave that sort of thing and
just over a period of time it it we kind
of lost that a little bit and so Jack
and took the decision there and and the
rest of us not assuming
took the decision that we were going to
fix a date we're going to fix a day so
we're now doing Monday to Wednesday
three days a week in the office still
giving people the flexibility to work
from home but Russian had the excuses of
things like you know
that day yeah or you know I need
to boiler man to come do I mean if you
need to do that you do it on Thursday
and Friday now okay nice
Alicia what have you seen in your
business because house jobs need to be
done on a Monday
fair I think for us I mean I absolutely
despise working from home okay I think
it's the devil okay you know don't be
wrong love doing my washing on a Monday
it's love all that but the day today for
me like a lot of people hide behind
working from home you know it's an
opportunity for them I'm having an admin
day
because then I've been done like you do
your admin in your day like that is your
day but I think for me
I find you know I do a lot of meetings
I'm out the office a lot but I'm not
working from home like it's flexible
because I can go anywhere I want and I
can you know I cover UK wide so I can go
to meetings Here There and Everywhere
but
it's difficult because I think a lot of
people see it they come into the
business and it's like do you do
flexible working what is that like what
is flexible working is it finishing
earlier is it having a day off like what
do people Define as flexible working
because it used to be working from home
now it's not like people want to come
into interviews thinking can I have
three days off because that's how they
see it and it might be old-fashioned but
I think the culture when people work
from home is I think that you know
it loses that Personal Touch of like
being in the like for me if I'm in the
office I'm bouncing ideas off people I'm
like what you think of this and I do
more when I'm around more people and so
I really struggle to grasp the concept
of a new consultant coming into a
business how are you developing Your
Role working from home like what what
are you doing staring at your washing
machine and you're saying client that's
not going to teach you how to recruit
like like that that's my personal
preference
it might be old-fashioned but that's how
I've been taught how to recruit is be
around people that know what you do and
learn from them but it it's different
everyone's different
Flex thanks
well I agree with what you can learn
recruitment by
you have to be in the office oh yeah the
best recruiters ever or in the office
fans
if you as soon
but yeah yeah I think like for me my
perspective now I speak to a lot of
recruitment companies right and I think
you know you just shared that I think a
lot of company owners found themselves
like just not owning what they were and
just sort of been oh you know a few
people asked for this let's do that so
what you guys are saying is like own
what you want if you want to be part of
that then great if not then this company
might not be for you and I think that
that's where sometimes people have had
the challenge I I hate to interrupt but
I feel like if you are performing and
you know how to do the job great work
from home on a Thursday work from home
on two whatever you want to do do it
whatever suits your lifestyle but when
you aren't performing and you are not
able to do the job or you don't know how
to do the job why are you working from
home like the people that are around you
the people are going to teach you how to
do your craft like what what are you
doing working it's it's such a gray area
because some people see it as a perk a
necessity but you're never gonna learn
sitting on your own at home unless you
listen to you know the recruitment
mental apps yeah I completely agree and
just like I don't know the finishing
point on that as well it's just a point
of efficiency as well you're not telling
me a message on slack or a message on
WhatsApp is quicker in getting something
done than asking someone at your desk
that's what I mean all for the the
hybrid model I enjoy the hybrid model
yep so like volume time you know when
you're in the office those days are
definitely needed yeah it's the final
thing on that then because we don't need
to speak about that all night but I
guess like you're passionate about it uh
we'll be here all night no I think Jamie
I just wanted to obviously the question
was you know you had that realization
how do you go about rolling out changing
because that might be helpful for people
like they might find themselves in that
predicament now yeah maybe we have made
some decisions because we thought that's
what employees wanted but actually you
know from what we can see performance
wise that has dropped they don't want to
piss everyone off they don't want to
then be known as a company that's old
school whatever it may be how did you
then go about going hey guys I actually
think we've yeah maybe put things in
that I actually don't believe in on
right for my culture and Company so how
did you go about actually rolling now
and communicating I was like look this
is how it now is you can be part of it
or you're not part of it how did you
roll that out
the people that are high on naturally
globally would be people that want to be
the best and we didn't change too much
but to scour business an aggressive
right
um You need to build a culture there is
no company in the industry that has
scoured a global business letting
everyone work from home that's an
absolute fact right successful business
we had to make sure that people wanted
to work our way um
our model and platform is proven to make
trainees right through to director level
seriously successful grow come out their
comfort zone and develop and that's what
I say to everyone right is join my
business if you want to be pushed and
join my business if you actually want to
double your billions and that's what we
do and we we removed a few people
um we set a standard and we drove it
seriously hard basically okay
that's what we have been doing over the
last couple of months yeah okay so to
build on last year then the word that I
found come up along my conversations are
being complacency
so I think the other element that has
come up a lot which I just want to touch
on here is in terms of complacency being
I think a lot of people enter the
industry over the last 12 18 months
there was a shitload of workflow
workflow so there's loads of stuff for
them to be working on
um most people then you know in terms of
saying like right guys let's really make
sure that we're continuing our outbound
activity Business Development whatever
that looks like in your company that
just really just didn't happen for a lot
of companies
um last year like yeah last year that's
a lot of the conversations that I've had
um so a lot of companies I've spoken to
they've found that over the last six
months when they're now trying to drive
a lot more of a BD culture people having
to be you know a lot more proactive they
found that actually looking at their new
crime base 80 of their new clients have
come from 15 20 of their staff and these
people are in 360 roles but actually you
know just got past roles from their
managers and they got used to that and
that's been their experience and now
it's been a real challenge for a lot of
people to transition into in their own
clients and new business Lewis I know we
spoke about this how one is that
something that you guys face to how did
you go about you know influencing and
changing those behaviors or helping
people on that Journey because I know a
lot of people struggle with that
yeah no absolutely it's definitely
something we faced um so the short
answer is we we quadrupled kpised
um the Lesser and the less ambiguous
answer is is that look uh Jack finds
some some inefficiency saying people's
Diaries you know I mean people weren't
using the time as best as they possibly
could and then and let's say someone was
putting four hours of business
development in their diary per day uh
the activity didn't didn't reflect that
so instead uh Jack came up with a very
good example which actually shared with
you didn't I
um but basically different things and
how you could optimize your diary still
with reasonable stuff in there an hour
and a half lunch time for resourcing in
the morning client meetings in the
afternoon but finishing the day with
with business development and really up
in that and we thought if everyone
actually put their mind to it we could
quadruple our output now our kpis before
were bare minimums whereas now they are
stretch targets and whatever sauce do I
lie what then give us an example so like
well we've quadrupled them so okay it
was okay you sound four times as many
times all the times as many Outreach as
what we were doing right okay got here
so what's that but that's one way we've
done it yeah obviously for people in
wiser normally you get to about
consultant level and that's when
business development is actually
expected of you okay actually bringing
on business now obviously for the people
that were more Junior than that it's a
bit of a scary situation right one
little actionable that we've done with
my team that seems to have been
effective I've got Darius in the crowd
somewhere and he'll tell you whether it
is or not
um but encouraging people to go for
coffee catch-ups even with candidates a
lot of people still hide behind a screen
if you avoid on the end of a phone or
you're a message on a phone you need to
get rid of it can't you shut the laptop
I can close the message and whatnot if
you become an actual real person to your
candidate to your client you take them
for a coffee you take them for a bit of
lunch or whatever automatically it's a
weird psychological thing but they're
like well no actually I'm not going to
just get rid of Darius because actually
I'm kind of
and then all of a sudden you start doing
that you start meeting relevant people
they don't need to be of use right now
but they need to be of use in the future
and to me that counts as a relevant
coffee can shop and count towards that
particular kpi so now whenever the
person that Darius met
six months ago hopefully in 18 months
time that person may well be an SDR
manager or progressing and have some
clout in that business and actually help
us out so that's little actionable
Jeremy I sent this did you not really
experience that
doesn't work this year yeah so did you
not feel like there was you know
complacency that that's what a lot of
people I've spoken to felt did you not
feel like that was happening in your
video last year last year
we still done well we've done very we
doubled last year so we obviously done
something right
um but
just
yeah what what did work last year is is
tougher this year so naturally you need
to work smarter or harder more
structured you need to have a better way
of how you position yourself you need to
be Innovative for future free thinking
sorry
um you need to make sure that you're not
just talking I believe not just talking
recruitment all the time and you're
talking about your products and how you
off on outcome driven services and
that's what the difference is for this
year is that the recruiters that do
great are the people that don't act like
recruiters they're the people that build
relationships offer Solutions
etc etc and you know the last few months
or a couple months for us we've had some
phenomenal months because people are
just turning the whole
um service to a Next Level Nas what you
didn't need to do last year because
people could just ping a CV out and you
know get a win out of it yeah you just
can't do that issue so that leaves
you've got a nice thing because I think
when we prepared for this all of you
shared that that journey of solutions
outcome focused So Lisa let me comment
you on that because I think a lot of
people here like being honest the reason
why we're speaking about this so many
people ask questions about business
development in all different ways
um so in terms of like my question here
was a lot of you spoke about setting
Solutions being outcome focused products
you'll mention that's something that
you've all had to really focus on have
been on a journey on so let me come to
you first on like why firstly
um you just spoke about it a bit there
and what do these products look like
what do they sound like I think that'll
be helpful for people do you know what
I'm like really torn between the two
because I completely get your
perspective but then I also massively
agree with yours because for me my whole
job is relationships like
everything else like the the people
will buy off you if they trust you and
that is the job and don't get me wrong
like I could get on with that speaker if
I had a pair of lips like I swear to God
like that's just my obviously but I also
think that at the moment like this year
last year was was a piece of piece like
I could send anyone to anyone and they'd
be like yeah I'll have him because they
needed them this year people have like
sales haven't been going through Cuts
have been made companies have been
structuring back so for me it's like
right well it's about the quality of the
person that's coming in but it's also
what else can you offer like so for me
personally as a billing as a billing
consultant because that's still what I
am you know can I offer reputational
structuring you know what is the market
saying about you do you draw a report of
what the Market's saying about you
they'll pay for that like they want to
know I speak to people every day what is
everyone saying gossip like a gossip
queen Jeremy like people love it people
love to know what people say about them
they will pay for that so reputation in
the market well the market you know
retainers you need to commit from the
start if you're going to search it they
need to know like well I'm going to pay
up front if you trust me enough to do
that service then why would you not pay
up front it's an easy conversation pay
up from paper search and pay on
completion easy I think also one other
thing is
um salary surveys we've been doing quite
a lot of them
um you know are you paying what you need
to pay in the market to get the right
people
um there's been actually in construction
an increase in a sharp decrease which
has been really interesting because
people aren't willing to pay the high
salaries anymore so we're having to
manage candidates a lot differently when
it comes to salary expectations how are
you having those conversations when it
comes to actual candidates I mean I put
something out every month which is like
a like a bit of a like a email to
everyone but I send out template CVS and
all sorts just to help people because I
think the best things in life are free
I get it on LinkedIn a lot does anyone
want one they're like yeah yeah I've got
hundreds of people like yes every one of
them and I'm you know if I can help in
any way possible that takes me out of
you're just a recruiter I'm a person you
know Malaysia like you either want
it or you don't
um
yeah yeah I'll help you in any way
possible
not just getting your good people yeah
the line of the podcast
um so tell me anything else because look
when we prepared for this I know you
told me about the you know you shared
the you just wasn't asking for retainers
enough you're surprised about actually
yeah no people will say yes you won't
hustle and help you felt like so you
also said that you know you wanna
um a really big project which was less
about ones and twos and like is there
anything else that right that project
came crashing down very quickly oh sure
okay sir I won't cry about it but it was
it's a sort of time we'll move on with
that one though to be fair but this is
this actually leads on really nicely
because
when in a tough Market you get very
trigger happy you know someone says to
you any 10 things and you're like oh
yeah look at all the whole delivery team
on it everyone do it and then all of a
sudden they go ah then they're being
pushed back they up I'm like you
absolutely bastard I'm like I've got to
explain this to someone like that's the
hard thing like it's managing your own
expectations when it comes to that but
also you know for me we've got a really
good delivery team that deliver on
everything like we can offer a really
well-rounded service where the person
that comes to us doesn't actually have
to go anywhere else we've got everything
you know we're a One-Stop shop okay all
right come to Anderson James get
everything okay but at the same time
it's really really hard because you've
got to meet those expectations you know
yeah I've got high standard some of the
people might not
it's not my problems
Lewis we spoke about this didn't we I
know you've been on a bit of a journey
with this yeah Solutions outcome not
like you said contingent goose chase
getting away from that what does that
actually look like sound like in in your
team's business yeah no no similar to
similar to Alicia we've been on a dumb
bro while goose chase is in the past
sort of six to nine months and it's got
to a point now where we've decided okay
we're just not gonna do contingent
anymore it's it's the bottom line so uh
we plan to be retained fully by October
and using sort of just deposit system
and then the rest on delivery but just
getting upfront commitment and getting
exclusivity on everything is really what
we're doing we took stock of what we
actually do for our clients and you'd be
surprised about how little some
recruiters actually do during processes
like throwing CVS we like to see at the
other end of the process that sort of
thing when in actual fact we took audit
and we were like
we're actually doing a lot here
like we're going above and beyond uh in
every way shape and form and we can
actually monetize that and sell it
against the contingent service so if you
want to continue we can do that but
we're going to charge more uh however if
you get retained you get the works and
guess what it's cheaper overall so to
give her give us like give us some of
the breakdown of like with contingent
this is what it is if you're working
this way what are some of the things I'm
not gonna give away Secret Sauce
instructed from that now
give you some of it man come on one
thing one thing May well be obviously
having a weekly pipeline catch up okay
and a shared spreadsheet of all the
talent that's currently going into that
pipeline which you wouldn't get with our
contingent service okay yeah
Jamie Solutions outcome I remember
um a while ago it might be like a Paris
event I saw you talking about like
solution uh stuff and that approach like
what what's been your perspective on
this how did you really drive this for
the team because one of I think this
ties into you can tell me but one of the
questions this was from a chat called
Troy the question was for Jamie apart
from attitude what else do you do your
Consultants do in order to sell Project
based contract Solutions and build the
numbers they do so I think this ties
into quite nicely people want to know
what does that look like in your
business the products like you said you
have to not be a recruiter to you know
be really competitive and great in this
market what does that look like for you
guys
yeah so we do it's so first of all we
identify projects that are in cloud or
whatever it is we identify and we we
sell our service to build teams
um for New York which is now rolled out
globally
um we're taking five products to Market
where my goal is in most businesses what
I see is perm contract fight against
each other I want to bring permanent
contract together how you do that is
perm sales contract contract sales
home sales contract contract sales perm
um that might sound a bit crazy but
if we train them to sell correctly
we will penetrate a client in so many
different ways so we've got fire
products we're taking to Market one's A
team's a service offering which is
statement of work one's teams of service
to hire one's contract once conduct high
and you're once retained so our goal is
every schedule called at Maya team have
is everyone will sell all solutions if a
client buys into one or the other they
bring on the rsme to enjoy that call to
then sell the rest of the solutions my
goal is for us to be the best company in
the market how we do that we train
people to be to sell the best to sell
anything
um and to provide an outcome based
projects solution Wrapped Around Talent
so that's our goal and that's what we've
taken to Market what are some of the
would you mind just sharing just some of
the differences in those I think that'd
be useful obviously said retained yeah
for quite a lot of people understand
that yeah just give us some of the high
level differences in those products yeah
so without going into detail of what
consultancies do because obviously own a
project they deliver a project on a
statement of work they own a project for
us we we will offer an sow where we give
the client control over the project so
effectively it's a Time material sow
we're also doing that to hire
consultancies can't offer people
directly to businesses to allow them to
hire we can offer that's the second one
okay the third one is obviously
contracts which is just self-explanatory
it's contract recruitment the fourth one
is contracts are high on the fifth one's
retained now the reason why we're
driving conduct tires so much is because
it's two fees what does that mean yeah
what does contract so you charge six
times up front uh sorry six months time
material and then you charge
um but a normal percentage to go
permanently after okay right so for a
sales consultant that's two fees so we
cut all of our contracts at six months
and for a salesperson they have the six
months revenue and then they get the
permanent Revenue after that so it's
basically kidding two birds of one stone
um okay I know everyone in Granola
that'll be helpful for people yeah yeah
that's fine great just out of interest
do you send like a sales debt oh that
was my next question yeah
yeah do you what yeah do you how do you
get like because I suppose a lot of um
we deliver training like a lot of the
time I'll be honest a lot of recruiters
I'll speak to don't use any sort of
visual assets to help them sell their
solution and it's very much like look
I'm Jamie I do this space believe in me
trust me like I'll deliver on this right
that's what we're selling rather than
you know having a visual asset that you
can use in a sales process this is what
we've done for companies like yours this
is our track record look if you say
yesterday this is the process this is
what we do
have you in your sales process do you
have like you said you're booking like
calls and then you bring people in if
it's relevant to you do you have like
visual A's and Pitch Decks that your
guys use to help you know sell those
Solutions so yes people don't buy into
what so whatever you say you are if
you're a cloud expert that delivers
Talent across Europe and North America
they don't buy into that people buy into
the how so I train people of how to
educate clients on how you actually
deliver into programs so when we set up
conversations we set an agenda follow an
agenda we send a
um like a call Deck then we join the
call and we present a call Deck no so my
team are trained on the call that so the
Codex based on Punchy words
um but they've all been trained to Deep
dive into everything from benefits to
advantages to everything we do from a
service
um and
how much do you think that's helped the
guys girls clothes
how much does that help aid the sales
process diversity
boys and girls
how much
I've just had a girl last month
associate dude 240k in her third month
so
yeah decent yeah okay
Louis Alicia you can tell me Lewis we
were speaking about this again we're
going grounded here but I think it'll be
helpful for people you've been on a
recent Journey with pitch decks why have
they helped you in the team yeah I know
absolutely I completely Echo a lot of
what Jay we just said they're not 240k
months or whatever well like I say sorry
we're pretty proud of our thing
I don't know we've used the pitch deck
now for the last sort of six to nine
months or so it is so important to us
because we've got such a great brand in
all of our communities and all of that
sort of thing people it's quite hard to
escape us sometimes on LinkedIn in our
Market yeah so it's important that we
have something good looking and and uh
straightforward that we can present when
Gwen actually selling the services key
things that we have in there is
obviously what we do how we do it the
brands and the case studies that we work
with yeah and actual relevant case
studies to the client that we're
actually pitching so making sure there's
brands in there that people will know
and then also the talent that we've
actually placed in those Brands to make
sure it piques their interest then also
as well game changer for us especially
in pitch and retained work has been
actually having visuals on the
commercials as to how things work yeah
working examples so yeah you were this
way across this exactly having a
comparison as to okay if you work with
this contingent it's going to be this
way we're going to charge you this much
however retained you're getting this
this and this and also you're going to
save x amount of money and just making
sure that's plain as hell yeah yeah and
he's showing the fence out on that
because I know you've had some recent
experiences and that's really weird
because last week I had a meeting about
that exact thing so I'm putting success
when I started doing quite low level
recruitment when I got into it you know
it was
average seven seven and a Half Men fees
like I've started doing quite a lot of
exact stuff but every time I speak to an
exact person they go can you send me
something about yourself and I'm sat
there thinking like I don't what
have you been sending then all oh
wow now I've just been going and just
being me like I'm like yeah this is me
and I'm like
at the end of the day like they want
tangible things to send to a HR
department or and it's an interesting
examine quite a different Journey
obviously I know obviously Jamie's you
know does what he does and Lewis does
what he does but for me it's like I'm
still quite early but I've done very
very well but I'm still very early in my
journey I've just been enjoying making
loads of money but go on go on the girl
but now it's like right how am I going
to elevate myself and that comes with
case studies you know people want to
know well what have you done for that
person so I put a big sales doc together
which is basically all about me the
business that we work with
um something that splits up our services
which is like retained exclusive
contingent and it's basically a tick and
cross you know if you want to do
exclusive because yeah yeah if you want
to do contingent you get this this but
you don't get that but it's it's all you
know round about that's what you can get
with it which is really really
interesting because I'm listening to
these two and I'm like she actually does
not a long time ago because like before
then you would just explain that and
talk through it and I would feel
anything right okay I would lit like I
know I could go to anyone and be like
I've got this person they'd be like yeah
I'll take anything anything
I know that I could go I could sell ice
to an Eskimo that's just one of my
talents yeah I also know that when it
comes to that silver exec exact Market
they love knowledge you know me and
James sat down and did a bit of a thing
the other day and it was like right you
know this is that that's that when you
get to this level up here you know you
need to have knowledge experience you
need to know people these will take
anything off you like anything but it's
it's a bit like not not low value
because I love that market like it's
been what's got me here today but it
doesn't take as much you just need a
good person okay these just love Gossip
they love to know what's going on who's
moving where all that yeah and
to have a sales deck that goes into it
is is great because they they want to
take it to HR and say well these people
on this and they want them to fill
director roles like they need that yeah
they don't yeah at least you had it on
the podcast the other day
um it was the Amy episode we released
last week we lost out to another agency
just simply because she spoke to the
internal or HR person they're then in
the board meeting talking about getting
certain things signed off the company
that she was competing against had you
know some Vision like some assets to
provide them and she just had her words
and like I'm a visual learner like I
love visuals so for me it's like yeah I
love it but other people might not be
like that but it is it is really
important to get something that says
what you do who you are what your
previous case studies are like anyone in
this room if you've not got it I would
10 out of 10 recommend doing it because
it'll elevates that next level like yeah
I love it love it so let's go into I'm
going to go into some questions from uh
gonna go into some questions from the
audience and then I'll bring the mark
out and then we can freestyle a bit so
my go a bit in a few different places
um here so Jamie do you have a delivery
team or not Jeff
yeah but it's very small we're not a 180
model at all
the only reason why we've got a delivery
team is for
like high volume yeah yeah because the
question like you let me know if you
think of this there's a question from
Henry how do you ensure that you create
a 180 business is able to both generate
the sales and also fill the roles about
causing a bottleneck on either side I
don't know if there's anything we're not
180 so okay the what's may not
successful is we all hunt we all are
360. go getting Relentless recruiters
that's what we are and that's what's
made us grow we're a business that wins
new clients we're not a business that
are have been amazing expanding clients
we'd have some very very big and great
accounts but what's made us successful
is the amount of brands that we win
every month and that's because of the
360 model
at least shows you have a delivery team
so just to recap there like from your
perspective how do you have these people
both generate the sales and also fill
the roles without causing a bottleneck
at either side so we've recently
experienced this like you know it's
difficult because the delivery team are
absolutely unreal like my delivery team
are great give them a role they'll fill
it copy anything toilet cleaner whatever
right they'll fill it
um you're not against toilet cleaners up
surely
anything they will fill it like they
just they know the pro it's all about a
process it's not about the job it's
about what you do with the job
um but for me I've been focusing very
heavily on bringing new business you
know to them and really really funneling
it into them
but then at the same time it's equally
as important for them to tell me what's
going on if I'm not doing candidate
stuff
what's going on in the market yeah who's
hiring who's doing this you know who's
moving where it's got to be a really
nice balance so if you've got a delivery
team
um anyone in the audience who's got a
delivery tip make sure that they're it's
a give and take relationship you can
funnel as many jobs into them as you
want make them as rich as you want and
you know give them whatever but they
still need to be feeding you whatever
you need out of the market for me it's
like who's hiring who's the hiring
managers you know where's the busiest
where have people just moved from if I'm
not getting that information I actually
can't build a desk or a market because I
do UK wide now so for me it's like you
know if I don't know a hire a manager in
a certain how am I going to find I'm
gonna have to go and ring them myself I
might as well fill the jobs myself as
well so it is quite difficult it's been
a transition for me because I've been
very used to filling my own jobs
managing my own clients having being a
massive control freak which I am and
letting that go but it's been working
and they've been doing really really
well and I appreciate every single one
of the delivery team that we've got
because they are so hard work and they
put the most amount of work in bought
what I would say is it's worked better
when they've given something back as
well it's not all give give to them
you've got to take a little bit as well
do you do you do you have that model not
really in terms of 102 or
it's what we used to like I've like
alluded to before it was a case of we
had almost like from the moment you buy
the researcher anymore you became almost
like a 270 model so team leads or senior
cons upwards would win roles and then
they would deliver them but in recent
times everyone's on the tools on BD now
yeah yeah okay that's not as much
anymore
um Jamie let me commission this I quite
a lot of this question this was from
Alicia
um
no no not for me
um what talk what top three things do
you do with a consultant when they hit
that recruitment wall
um you know it might be a certain number
they keep hitting the 250 Grand Mark
they just struggle to get over that next
level like you know any one to three
things that you found really help people
break through the next barrier of
performance start maybe limiting beliefs
or thing oh I'm always only able to do
300 Grand a year whatever it may be
anything there to share that you found
be really helpful for people to overcome
those performance barriers so it first
starts with a word something about the
words that come out people's mouths
because if they talk that then it's
actually going to happen
um I'm huge about habits and what people
do in their personal life and what they
create
reflects what you actually do within the
organization as well and obviously their
career and I'm big about people self
reviewing so as long as you're getting
someone to self review or yourself
reviewed naturally
they're going to self-evaluate and
self-learn and have more solutions
before they even come to meetings I
spend about an hour and a half every
week just self-evaluating and reviewing
and I preach that across my whole
organizations that's probably one
um two is
ensuring that they are going back to
basics a lot of people forget about
doing the basics Basics get recruiters
to being great but then once they're
great they drop off and forget about the
basics so it's obviously retract not
true training but re-reiterating what
got them to where they are now and
they're just on that cruise because we
hear that a lot about what are the
basics like like how do you describe the
basics from your view like what are the
basics that you go right how did you get
there like what is it that you reinforce
yeah it's it's simple recruitment is so
easy if you just make it easy
um speed's a great candidate it's not
good candidate speak to Great candidates
great candidates work at Great companies
to extract commercial information once
you've got the commercial information
you chase Dan relentlessly but you map
out the client to ensure you get in
there okay get that just do a bit more a
little bit closer yeah yeah I'm gonna
eat it soon
um just a little bit so once you've
extracted commercial information you
chase that once you chase it you pitch
well once you pitch well you control the
client there are four pillars that I
discuss with my business all the time
keep it simple and that will get you to
where you need to get to love that
perfect was there a third thing when I
thought that was two Back to Basics
language what are we saying one more
thing or no self-reviewed self-isl
review nice habits and language
self-reviewing and back to back to
basics love that Lewis you're you know
on that leadership Journey what have you
found to be useful in helping people
around you have performance barriers
talk to me anything else yeah no this
may come across as like micro manager to
a lot of people but like yeah you do
quadruple it could be like yeah
um no full order like just full audit or
more order all the processes just what
you do from start to finish yeah things
aren't going right or you know they're
not going where they should be it's one
of those things where Paula Darius is in
the crowd who she didn't come now but
we're all sat there before
where Lucci has gone through everything
being like well okay where's the mental
block we do yeah we know the textbook we
know what we do we know the recipes and
make sure that we're a successful we're
producing successful services and yeah
and placements and all that sort of
thing where is it going wrong and yeah
how many times out of ten you find it
then you find it just going through
through everything from start to finish
let's make a placement together and yeah
and tell you what most of the time
you'll be like okay well this area isn't
as efficient as it could be okay you
know you're focusing too much on
candidate registration supposed to doing
your business development activity for
example I don't know but yeah there's
always dive into yeah okay dive into it
and it takes you know a couple of days
and then before you know it you find a
deep
issue that you can put your resolve uh I
had quite so not not interested in the
conversation of like oh our robot's
gonna take our jobs Vibe but a lot of
people message about like AI so
generally I'm gonna come to you on this
um people work in a different ways but
this question here from Idris which was
how has your company incorporated AI
Technologies to streamline your
Recruitment and operational we have
those okay
yeah we have you haven't okay special
crew has learned doing the job properly
if you rely on Tech and Tech and Tech
then you're going to rely on Tech if you
can we have LinkedIn recruiter we have
some soil
sauce
you have LinkedIn recruit so Zoom info
did you say yeah again that's a bit of
tech but let's rely on Tech yeah
um link some career Zoom info and that's
it okay
Alicia AI Technologies in the
recruitment process p up people do not
buy off robots like what the are we
doing like people buy off people we need
great relationships like at the end of
the day right so me and Jamie right if
I've got something that you want are you
gonna buy it off a robot if I ring you
and say hello no no no but we're not in
no we're not interested in that hey I
mean it's like that's what it's not what
else that's not the question it's not
the question is like are you utilizing
technology to I don't know screen CVS
quicker format CBS quicker like are you
implementing no we've got we've got a
formatting system
so we've got like a formatting system
that we send it out and then they bring
it back within two hours that's great
like but I think it calls oh so is that
a good sign
um no I think to be fair for us
when it comes to the only way that we're
going to be able to make sure that those
people are good and those people are
right for the job as if we do it
ourselves okay and you can invest like
to be fair like I've been speaking
Stones about this recently and like we
have been investing quite a lot in
different systems for our team but not
for the market you know we do
personality profiling that's fine but
that's obviously a thing that questions
that you answer and it goes from there
I think when it comes to actually AI
technology to make it more advanced no
because people don't want that like they
want to make sure that a person has
looked at that that knows that person to
make sure that the personality fits that
the profiles right oh my God
that's right so it's a lot further than
I I agree with that I think a lot of
people like I'd say probably in your
Market it's a bit more applicable
because that's what your Market is but
for construction yeah you know if I'm
looking selfishly in tunnel vision
you build in xyzad do you need AI
probably not okay it's probably not
applicable to my market but that's me
being selfish Louis what are you saying
sorry mate this question is going to
fall straight on its ass because again
we don't really do much so no it's not
us when it's us a lot of people met
initiative God is abusing the abuse the
AI writing assistant to write a LinkedIn
post how'd that go Snapchat one other
than that other than that no they're not
with our processes it's all people led
cool so I'm
um I'm gonna bring a microphone out
um in a sec I'm gonna ask these guys one
more question but if any of you that do
have a question and curious to ask these
guys to you know dig into something
maybe they've said
um but let me you know finish with you
guys on this and then we'll see what the
audience had to say or want to ask you
um this is just a question from Alice uh
Alicia I'll come to you first which was
you know if there was just one thing you
would have implemented in the early
stages of your recruitment career with
the Hines that you have now what would
it be
planning yep yeah I was shy like I was I
literally was like I'll just go into the
office and see what happens today you
have to go in with a plan you know
you've got to know what you're doing I
always say candidates for the morning
beat in the afternoon candidates will be
BD I could go on all day about it but I
see so many people coming into
recruitment
and they go into the office and like I
don't know what I'm doing today you've
wasted a day already if you go in and
don't know what you're doing you might
as well just not go in goodbye that's
the hardest thing but I also think that
I faked the first three years of my
career like I was literally I thought
yeah I'm gonna go I'm gonna be this
person that people wanted me to be I
became more successful When I Was Myself
and some people hate it some people love
it don't get me wrong I get that but it
got me so much further because at least
then if I I can own my like you
know I get where I am but
I faked so much time and just be
yourself like no one needs to know this
watered-down version of you people
someone and a client that pays a lot of
money will love you for the way that you
are because you are the way that you are
Louis
yeah I think one thing that'll be
massively valuable to me earlier on is
actually knowing what a good outbound
message looks like like my messages used
to be horrific they used to be like
small dissertations with every single
service line that we do everything about
us our founding story like all sorts so
they were just horrific so actually
learning about that learning about
personalization from the off and
actually what's going to grab a
prospect's attention knowing that from
the off that would be another able to me
Jamie round us out one thing uh creating
personal habits
um I wish I'd done it a lot earlier I
preached about in my business and just
creating personal habits to allow you to
be great at what you do you won't be
great without having good personal
habits
um most love it
um
let's do some questions before we finish
who's got the courage to ask the first
one right let's go oh uh I'll come with
the mic
well it's too fair you actually argument
Mark actually yeah here we go
hello guys
um what would be your favorite question
or your top killer question to ask
anyone that you're interviewing to join
your business and why
video first I don't ask questions really
I just Grill uh do I like you or not
yeah
um it depends what level it depends what
level who keeps docking over these
bottles Savage
it's like bowling alley
the question that I normally ask
especially if we employ a lot of people
that haven't necessarily done
recruitment before at least we used to
but asking them okay
unreal Savage
absolutely Savage that's your team by
the way what they expect the hardest
thing about the job to be and actually
just seeing like where they're where
their heads currently at so like if you
were to come into this role tomorrow be
here what's the thing that you think
you're gonna like struggle the most with
or or need the most coaching him like
it's normally a good good way to see
where they're at and actually how much
they understand about what they'd be
doing because as we know it's not all
champagne and Roses nice uh yeah
yeah
just I've got a question for Jamie
um so we've done quite a lot of stamina
work stuff within our business and 100
think it's a great way to do Recruitment
and like that's how he builds good
relationships you win bigger clients you
get like decent margins
um I'd say there's some people in our
business that do it very well but I've
TR I've struggled to maybe roll out to
lots of different teams and I think like
commercial Acumen is quite a big part of
that if you're trying to have a
conversation with cios and Sell
Solutions so how would you identify
those people in the interview process
and then how would you train them to
like have those conversations with
senior people
last last year so I'm I'm not I wouldn't
say that I've I'm academically great
um my top biller is probably the
thickest person ever as well so
um
but he did get my biggest account anyway
um I don't it's it's not it's not in
it's not an interview process for me
it's about how you train people
um I love uh the same poor hungry driven
that's the type of people I look for
um why I want people to want to make
some of themselves
um I say to everyone that I interview we
will make you better and that comes with
a platform I talk about a what why and
how
um it's not about communicating and
training people on the what it's about
the why it's about the how
um and I think if you can have a good
training program
um or training modules that's repeatable
that's replicable and that's resilient
that is a scalable way to roll out good
ways of working
um training products offerings and
solutions right so that's that's my
personal opinion on it is how you train
people is giving them the education of
how they sell it and how it actually
comes across to the client because like
I said I've got some people in my
business and no one that I hire
in my London office I don't think
anyone's got a University degree so I'm
not all for that Hannah maybe my head of
talent
um but yeah I think it really just comes
down to the actual platform and I'm big
about a platform and how people can
Elevate on a platform
um so that's what I'd put it down so
thanks
uh you guys mentioned that 2022 was a
lot easier than 2023 uh just like to get
your insights into the rest of 2023 and
if how you're going to combat those
problems I know you said you do you
increase your kpis I hope you don't have
to do that again
um appreciate just how you're going to
basically go over those problems if yeah
and you're gonna rise in the rest of the
year basically sorry mate I missed the
last minute yeah like what how are you
going to get over the problems that are
going to come up in the rest of 2023
basically
if there are any like if you've seen
into the market you said well I hope
it's not like Panda or anything like
that but I know
um it's just the the move towards
retained is the biggest thing for us
it's weeding out the silent wasters and
I mean we've all been there we've all
been on briefs where we think this is
going to be the best account since
sliced bread and everyone's going to be
millionaires but then it's like yeah it
doesn't work out that way
um and taking an L early on and maybe
them signing with the competitor on
contingent terms is probably not the
worst thing in the world if you're
sticking to your guns right now and
making sure you're working in a way
which you know when you hand it over to
someone in your team or you work at
yourself that you're actually working
towards your next promotion Target or
earning that next bit of commission yeah
I'd probably agree with that I think
you've got to be able to walk away
that's the key thing
um when it comes to retainers they are
really really hard because I had major
imposter syndrome I could I couldn't
sell a retainer to save my life and then
one day I was like I'm gonna do it
retained and they went all right okay I
went can I only have done it well
they've actually agreed to it and then
from then on it was dead dead easy
um but the key thing I would say is for
the rest of this year it will get better
you know I put a bit of an inspirational
post that I've Linked In the other day
giving everyone a bit of a hype talk
it'll get about like the sun will shine
again but the main thing is going to be
job control you know you've got to make
sure that your clients are committed you
could spend weeks and weeks and weeks
filling a job that will never go
anywhere you know the best way to find
that out is at the start make sure that
before when you qualify in the job
when can they actually offer someone you
know what date do you offer someone when
do you want them to start and if they
say I don't know it off like ignore
like that that's it done if they cannot
give you an answer you will not get an
answer in three weeks after the
interview process you have to be really
really cut throat and make sure that if
you know as I said I've been through it
recently like a client led me on LED me
on gave them the full service and then
they just went we're not doing it right
now I was like it's like that's a
lot of money to let go but you've just
got to be Savage like think about it
time is money how are you spending your
time is it something that's closest to
the money or furthest away is it a maybe
or is it a hundred percent that's going
to go through like that that is my best
advice
I agree as well but I think no problem
the mo the market has not slowed down by
any means stretch it's leveled out and
that's the biggest thing people complain
the market slow down it's not
the market is leveled out to what it
should be like a normal recruitment
Market
um for us we're still growing for us
we're still billing for us we're still
opening more offices why because we're
continuously upskilling the people that
we have in the business we're
continuously training them we're
continuously coaching them I hate the
word management I agree with what you
said as well is we get under the Bonnet
we do desk mots every week
um midweek so
the reason why all these companies
there's so many companies letting people
go right now is because
at Target's a
um the way they drive the business is
and that's why they they looked
good because they always hiring all
these people but then they're making
redundant all these people as well
for us we bring them in put them on a
great platform drive them in the right
direction and train them great
and that's what's got us to allow to
grow and continue to see grow
um it's it's the upskill and it's
continuous upskilling and developing
people
um that will outbeat anyone else
thank you
um
so many final questions or yeah okay
final one then
I won't ask you Lou so see you every day
but what's the best way to keep your
team motivated when markets are
challenging like a lot of us have been
in recruitment for a long time and we've
been through the times we've come
out the other side so what advice would
you give to your team to just keep
pushing on and keep motivated
um one thing I would say is do the
little things that will lead on to the
big things like everyone thinks that the
job is
get a job Bill complete done like you
have to do the little things to ensure
that you're still relevant you know
build a LinkedIn profile is absolutely
massive you need to stay relevant in
your Market whether that's actually
staying relevant with clients on an
email Trail but LinkedIn will be your
biggest tool and what you do in a quiet
Market will be key to succeeding
you know mate hey while the sun shines
as they say like when it's busy those
the people that will go to are the
people that see you when things are
quiet do little freebies here and there
there's nothing wrong with that like no
one's sitting there saying you have to
take bleed a penny out of everyone for
everything if someone says to you do you
know what people are paying this let me
send you a little rundown of a salary
survey look don't worry about it they
will remember that more than anything
you've got to do things that are
memorable to people that will make you
rise when the market Rises don't get me
wrong it is terrible at the moment like
I'm not sitting there like don't be
wrong we're doing well we're building
we're growing as a business we're doing
all these good things but it's tough
like people aren't hiring what they used
to hire but what you do in that time is
really really key to when things get
busier again you want to be at the
Forefront of these people's minds
constantly pumping them with new
candidates you know who's good good
salary surveys what the reputation's
saying like do these little things that
will build it then as soon as it gets
busy they'll be like I've got 20 rolls
here like what do I do with them don't
worry I'll help you out like that's how
it works like people love it when people
support them in the dark times but I
remember when I've been through
times I remember all the friends up
there for me
that is recruitment like that that's the
top bottom of it
it's for me
don't start by saying how do you
motivate people through tough times I
don't believe it is a tough time in
recruitment right now it's leveled out
and that's the first thing I want to say
um
you inspire people you motivate people
you set Visions you drive them in the
right way I say to all of my team I'm I
don't hire you to be your friend I hire
you to make you great so the the people
that bring on people just to be their
friend or don't train them in the right
way or don't drive them the right way
that doesn't get results and in this
market right now where it has leveled
out results are key
um we have missions across every office
right now which we've we've collaborated
to to get to that point
um it's reminding people who the
business are what we represent how we
drive how we work but again it comes
down to the motivation it comes down to
inspiring people it doesn't come down to
oh it's a Market what are
we going to do let's panic and let's
just you know put an arm around his
shoulder that's not that doesn't work
what works he's driving him and coaching
him to be absolutely great at their jobs
and that's a big thing for us is I talk
about the platform a lot we have built a
very very good platform to inspire
people to be great and I've got some
phenomenal bills in my business that are
doing phenomenal numbers still
regardless of people saying it's slowed
down it's level down all of that it
hasn't it has only slowed down if you
allow it to slow down and that's my
biggest thing I never ever ever
communicate across my business because I
don't believe in it
just on that though I would say like it
depends it depends who you are as to
when it's quiet what do you do in that
quiet time you know therefore why
they're quiet no no not quiet I'm not
being like if say for example you've not
got as many jobs
what do you do
work hard turn up listen no I I get that
from my perspective because I'm I'm
billing what I'm billing but I'm saying
like I'm talking from a billion
perspective you're talking for a
management like I'm talking from I'm
you're talking from a wider team
perspective what do I do day to day I'm
talking from the all right so I've
Cherry I do what you do but I'm saying
right now so I I've Cherry Picked people
to work directly for me in my business
I've got about six or seven billers that
report to me they all do a minimum of
anywhere between 100 to 200k monthly
right and these are people that don't
come in and look at a there stay
self-reviewed before they come into the
week they're people that have the right
plan we talked about planning a lot have
the right plan have the right goals have
the right motivation have the right
activity let it go out and that's what
it comes down to people without our
quiet in this market is because they've
made themselves quiet yeah they're not
able in the right activity they're not
doing the right things and that's that's
therefore at the end of the day and
they're the people that get made
redundant right they're the people that
get pushed out companies because people
need to work to generate money at in the
day and that's how I look at it right is
that there are a lot of companies that
are doing that but people quiet because
I do think this Market will weed out
recruiters like it does yeah that's
a given but I think what I'm saying is
like from my perspective you know
looking at
personally I'm not quiet but if I was
looking at someone else who was sitting
there on a desk and they were like not
as busy as I need to be yeah again it's
their fault but what can they do to give
themselves that oomph to get them busy
again you know it's hard like some I
think it's difficult for me because I
look at people every day and I'm like
you know like what are you doing like
I'm busy I'm running around giving jobs
xyzed whoever but what are these people
doing that sit there and going God I've
not had a job in all week I've not done
this like it can be disheartening and
after six weeks of that you will
probably leave like you'll probably
think recruitment's not for me but how
can you edge them out I got I completely
agree with you like that's what I'm
saying like I get what you're saying but
I think it's difficult when you're in
that spot because I've been there bear
in mind I did three years no billing
like I was at my job like don't get
me wrong
but I still carried on why because I had
a why I knew exactly what I wanted to do
but I didn't do the day-to-day habits
which is exactly what you're talking
about
but yeah it's just like what can you do
when you're in that headspace of God
like the Market's tough yeah get out of
it it's personal development it's all
these self-help stuff but it's harder
when you're in that I got what you're
saying I know I know what you yeah I
know what you're saying I get I get it
um
so look I think before we give these
guys a hand
um massive thanks to all of you for
coming I think I'm gonna leave it there
I think I just want to say
we've um we've put your coats and bags
upstairs it's gonna be absolutely
Carnage if we will try and go
upstairs and get our coats of stuff so
hoping if you can help us out and if we
could just go we'll finish there and
then
um like if the guy's closer to that uh
door can just start first and then get
their bags and stuff
um that's been really helpful but let's
give a hand to these guys thanks
everyone
there we go